recueillement et dignité les proches de
rachid ont tenu à rendre un dernier
hommage silencieux à leur ami tué la
semaine dernière d'un coup de couteau
plus de 400 personnes ont marché en
mémoire de cet homme de 32 ans
originaire du quartier de la chanaye à
mâcon impliqué dans le milieu associatif
est très apprécié ils avaient tous un
général ont joué ensemble qu'on était
petit
c'est vraiment triste que justice soit
faite
oui ça me met vraiment c'est une
personne très très très très agréable au
quotidien on a fait du sport ensemble
c'est une personne agréable à vivre
souriant très honnête
jamais jamais un mot plus haut que
l'autre
très souriant et aimable la semaine
dernière à ce carrefour
rachid veut s'expliquer avec un
automobiliste alors qu'ils se sont
doublés à plusieurs reprises mais
l'homme sort un couteau et plante la
lame dans le coeur avant de se rendre à
la police sans savoir qu'il vient de
tuer rachida nanouche la famille de la
victime attend maintenant une avancée de
l'enquète pour pouvoir faire son deuil
notre espoir c'est que toute la lumière
soit faite sur cette affaire et que
toutes les circonstances qui entourent
cette affaire soit mise en évidence
il y va effectivement ici de de
l'apaisement
il va également du deuil de que doit
faire la famille l'enquète a été confiée
à un juge d'instruction
et hier la police a lancé un appel à
témoins pour tenter d'en savoir plus sur
les circonstances du drame